all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are wrapping up invincible
volume 16 family ties and this one we
basically follow up we're really kind of
pick up with the new inventor kind of
continue on with the new invincible
right zandal this guy's pretty cool but
the whole thing behind this is as you
guys know he's kind of picking up for
mark uh while mark's incapacitated due
to the scourge virus and he really kind
of operates at a distance because
obviously if invincible suddenly became
black people would ask questions
and so zandale's idea was like i'll stay
far enough away that they can see the
costume colors but they can't see my
skin color and so in effect they'll know
they're at least believe they're still
getting invincible mark as opposed to a
different guy because remember that was
the biggest issue people had that where
you had invincible incorporated and
different heroes were being sent in on
behalf of mark to deal with various
threats that people were essentially
asking for refunds because what they
paid for was mark they didn't pay for
anything else i mean at the end of the
day you'd think that what they were
paying for was to have their problems
solved right i mean if i need to hire an
attorney it doesn't really matter to me
that i don't get the guy on the sign
what matters to me is that they do their
job and that i basically get what i need
in terms of winning my case whatever the
case happens to me so the thing about
this is you basically got like the
walking dread which is obviously like
robert kirkman kind of you know doing a
play on his own comic the walking dead i
mean this guy's not a big deal he's like
tearing up some big transformers or
whatever and then gets pummeled by
xandel and that's basically it that's
not really important the important thing
here
is when we switch over to freddie
mercury and i still gotta say it's a
little weird to call him freddie mercury
but apparently you guys love it so we're
just gonna keep on calling freddie
mercury but uh but the crazy thing about
this is freddie mercury has this
conversation with dinosaurs now remember
dinosaurs it's kind of like this
incredible hulk type thing right where
basically this guy turns into dinosaurs
but dinosaurs is actually the genius
right so it's like if bruce banner was
kind of an idiot and he turned into the
incredible hulk who is basically
professor hulk right just like this pure
genius and you know just wildly
intelligent and so where dinosaurs is
like look like i'm not here you know
causing trouble or anything like that
and even where he says where dinosaur
says like i've gained access to your
your you know systems and so on and so
forth he's like what i need is to be
able to work alongside your scientists
right like i need to be able to speak
with your scientists because i have some
questions now as you guys know freddie
mercury killed the lead scientist that
was here because a lead scientist had
gained information that freddie mercury
didn't want anybody else to know what
that information is we don't know yet we
simply just know that's what he did and
so following the defeat of the walking
dread zandio goes to visit adam eve and
then kind of puts the moves on i mean
adam eve of course is is struggling with
the fact that like mark may not recover
from the scourge virus then he might die
i mean this guy zandal made the total
wrong move here but as he's talking to
her you know he was like look you know
if ever you know if you need anything
you know let let old zendale know right
zandale he's a swiss army knife right i
mean whatever ails you zandale's got the
cure
[Music]
not in so many words but you kind of see
what's happening right you know he's
like he's like i can i can stay here and
keep you company if you want and that's
when she's kind of like are you trying
to have sex with me he's like no no no i
mean unless you want to you know it's
it's terrible right that zandale is
telling a woman who's struggling with
the fact that her husband might die if
she needs a little
physical relief that he's there for her
of course so that immediately tells him
get out of here you end up switching
back over to thrax and this is where
freddie mercury basically spills the
beans to a degree now he doesn't say it
on the nose but we can figure it out
pretty easily right like he says i'm
told that the period of time where you
can pass on the scourge virus to others
has passed all this time we've been
studying you the virus your dna all this
hard work has proven unnecessary
you're going to survive it is rare for
one as young as you to be able to fend
off the scourge virus naturally this is
something that has stumped my scientists
but i know why of course you will
survive the virus failing to do so would
betray your bloodline for thousands of
years i have acted as grand regent
charged with the task of locating the
lost son of argol placing him on the
throne of viltrum your father you
no i will not yield my position to
traitors if i have to forfeit our time
here on earth then so be it essentially
what freddie mercury is saying here is
that mark and his father are directly
tied they're direct descendants to the
rightful throne of viltrum they are in
effect the rightful kings that what
would happen here if freddie mercury
were to to yield his position is that is
that nolan right omniman would step in
as the king of the vulture might race
and that mark would be his son he would
be prince of the viltromite race but
freddie mercury refuses to let that
happen and in fact he actually goes to
attack mark right goes to choke him out
and says well if i'm lucky then maybe
fortune will smile down on me and
they'll believe the scourge virus took
you right that no one's going to ask any
questions you know that my scientists
will say man the scourge virus took him
god is so so terrible and freddie
mercury would be like yeah man it's just
so bad and that'll be the end of it no
one will ask any questions he's like all
of this could work out and look at the
way he looks he looks maniacal right and
it kind of makes sense if you are a
person like him who is by all standards
of measurement immortal and for
thousands of years you have held a
position of power and then like that the
position of power comes into question
you would be very very disinclined to
give that up right you would be like no
like i'm not going to give up my
position of power that sure i mean it
sounds like it'd be a nice idea to say
of course i will right it's the right
thing to do it's fair right but like who
cares about fair there's only winners
and losers that's all there ever is and
so because of this he goes in to
basically take out mark now in the
middle of that he's interrupted by
dinosaurs who immediately attacks them
but as we know dinosaurs has nothing on
freddie mercury and in fact he destroys
his hand in the process and that's one
of the things you're freddie mercury is
like i'm suspecting this didn't really
go the way that you thought it would
right that that like you're realizing
just now how stupid it was for you to do
what it was that you were doing now the
thing about this and this is what makes
dinosaurs so cool this guy's always got
contingencies and his contingencies have
contingencies right this guy is always
prepared and so what he says here is he
says your home planet velcro was
destroyed all that history lost forever
i would imagine that there must be a
great many items of tremendous value
aboard this ship the last vessel of the
viltrumide empire it was unwise to give
me complete access to your files i've
learned a lot over the last few hours
enough to know that you don't want
anything bad to happen to this ship and
where freddie mercury immediately begins
to pick up on what it is this guy's
doing essentially blackmail the response
to dinosaurs is i've been able to
pinpoint a few key areas where an
element could be altered climate
adjusted to cause disastrous explosive
even results i've got systems monitoring
my heart rate as it rises it will set
off a series of explosions inside this
ship and where freddy's like you really
expect me to believe that's something
that you would do he was like not at all
but if my calculations are correct one
should be going off right about now boom
when like this huge explosion goes off
in the distance and that's when he's
like now that i have your attention uh
why are you here to kill invincible
right like why are you doing this like
you and your team were like adamant
about saving his life less than an hour
ago right you were like you wouldn't let
anybody into this room for fear that he
might die and he's a member of the
viltrumite race even if he's only part
human and you need as many vulture mites
as you can possibly have so what's
changed what did you discover that would
cause you to reconsider this and then of
course freddie murphy won't give him an
answer and then it's just like you ask
too many questions and then immediately
goes in to attack him now the funny
thing about this is that while freddie
mercury is absolutely pummeling
dinosaurs the response to dinosaurs is
like like i warned you like do not do
this like i warned you that every like
as my heartbeat elevates these
explosions will start going off and all
these different explosions are going off
in different locations but this is
something that i want you to notice here
right that where dinosaurs goes to
basically bite freddie mercury and his
teeth just shatter all over the place
and freddie mercury basically rips his
mouth in half that the reason why this
is happening that where freddie mercury
has an absolute allegiance to the
vulture might race seemingly before
anything else and that he would never
let anything get in the way of the
viltrumite race the reality of this and
really what's going on here is him
maintaining his role as the leader of
the viltrumite race now supersedes
everything else that because they are
essentially immortal well i would not
say his stance is now coming from the
perspective that like hanging onto these
trinkets and bobbles it's really just
reminiscing and and really holding on to
a bygone age that in reality they can
always rebuild they can always find a
way to bring that part of their history
back that it's not the end of things if
this whole ship gets destroyed that yes
it would suck and yes it'd be really
harsh on them but what's more important
than that is maintaining his power
maintaining his control and so
ultimately overcoming dinosaurs
basically freddie mercury takes off to
eliminate whatever these little bombs
happen to be now that the heartbeat of
dinosaurs is essentially dropping off
and so in the moment when freddie
mercury's absent dinosaurs snatches up
mark and then takes off out of there in
a skate ship as fast as they possibly
can the crazy thing about this is that
at an undisclosed location which is one
of the secret bases of dinosaurs that it
just comes crashing down and in the
process mark basically wakes up but when
he gets up and he looks out he looks
what appears to be dinosaurs who's been
killed in the crash with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end i
know this one was shorter than the other
ones but thank you guys for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace